with the pandemic a bunch of restaurants
have gone online quote unquote they have
the QR codes right and something that I
think of every single time as an
internet marketer is why they are not a
b testing their menus and so I think
someone needs to go and create a b
testing software that restaurants can
ingest super easily
[Music]
what's up Steph Steph is back uh back in
the house one of the most requested
return guests of all time
um we should have you on more what are
you doing now by the way you uh you left
the hustle slash HubSpot you went to
Andreessen is that where you're at still
are you doing other things yeah exactly
I'm at a16z I'm their new podcast host
so they've had a podcast for like seven
or eight years and then it went on
Hiatus they looked for a new host and
that's me we haven't gone live yet but
we will be soon every time you come on
you bring this like document that's
basically like
it's sort of what me and Sam do but when
me and Sam do an episode we have like
two or three bullet points each like
three words and I have two and he has
two and that's how we prepare you send
this like Encyclopedia Britannica of
topics ideas like half fake things in
your head
um so like I'm looking at this this is
like seven or eight pages or something
like that oh no 12 pages long so um we
have a lot to choose from so where do
you want to start I wanted to share this
one idea I think I've actually talked
about it on another couple pods but
with the pandemic a bunch of restaurants
have gone online quote unquote they have
the QR codes right and you pull up the
menu some restaurants have reverted back
to the physical menu but tons of
restaurants are still using these QR
codes and something that I think of
every single time as an internet
marketer is why they are not a b testing
their menus and so I think someone needs
to go and create a b testing software
that restaurants can ingest super easily
and the basis of this is well a if you
think about what has made so many
internet companies successful it is the
fact that they have these alternate
worlds that they can a B test right
Google home page are we using this font
or this font I'm using this color this
color Netflix you know Amazon every all
of these large internet companies have
used this but also there's the
restaurant equivalent so the hustle did
a story on this woman Michelle banesh
and you can just look up design
restaurant menus the hustle or something
like that to get the article but we
wrote about this woman who her job was
literally to go redesign menus physical
menus and based on her understanding of
human psychology orientation there's
like this Zed or Z effect on the menu
and the way people scroll she was able
to figure out how to get one restaurant
just as an example to bring in nine
dollars more per customer by redesigning
their menu same products but just the
orientation the order of the menu the
design of it and I was thinking why
aren't restaurants not using this as in
now we have the QR code which allows us
to direct someone to any unique link
right we have the digitization of this
and so you could hire someone like
Michelle and she could probably figure
out how to do this for you or someone
should be just create a software that
allows restaurants to do this they don't
need to change their menu at all but
they can mess around with the menu
design the same way you mess around with
landing page design and get higher
conversion and of course the average
restaurant owner is not going to know
how to do this and that's why I think
there needs to be just some sort of
software that says hey we can increase
your conversions right by 50 we can
increase your average customer value by
three dollars whatever it is and I I
haven't seen it anywhere
this is amazing
um this is great I remember so I started
a restaurant back in the day my very
first startup was a restaurant and we
were but when we finally got to launch
long story short we were like um do we
want to launch a physical restaurant we
got to sign this 10-year lease with a
personal guarantee that sounds scary and
our Mentor kind of was like could you
test your concept by doing delivery only
and basically it was like a cloud what a
cloud kitchen is today but this was back
you know more than 10 years ago now
where there was no doordash there was no
ubereats at the time but it was like
What If people could just order online
what if you just had a kitchen nearby
downtown there was no physical seating
there's no there's no storefront you
just deliver and we were like uh okay
listen so we tried it and when you do
that you're really conscious of well our
whole menu is online so that means we
could run a test to just see like what
makes people order more or not and so we
did the most basic of a B test the first
thing we did was we were trying to lower
prices and we talked to this guy Dan
ariely who was um he wrote this book
predictably irrational
and we were like Dan uh hey we're you
know three dudes trying to build this
like sushi restaurant startup you know
um do you know anything about the
restaurant industry and he's like I know
a lot about the restaurant industry he
goes I get paid by companies to come in
and help them with either the menu or
like he told us about some experiment I
think Panda Express had paid him a bunch
of money to do to basically say could we
get people we have healthy items on the
menu and people tell us the reason they
don't eat here is because it's unhealthy
but nobody orders the healthy items so
like what gives and he's like oh humans
are predictably irrational they'll tell
you one thing and then they won't do it
and he the one test he had made was when
you walk into a Panda Express instead of
putting both items on the menu and just
having you choose it was right when you
walked through the door it would say
there was like a little angel path it's
like if you're gonna eat healthy go this
way and there was like the dev you're
going to eat indulgently you know like
if you want full flavor go this way and
when people make that choice upon
walking in and then they only see a menu
of those items like they were happier
with their choice and they ordered more
of those items and so he like figured
out that was the only way he could
design this restaurant to do that one
thing
um
and so similarly he was like oh he goes
oh yeah I can help your business your
prices are too low and we go what do you
mean like everybody says Sushi's too
expensive we're trying to make it more
affordable like how is that a bad thing
well you know like what are you talking
about man we're trying to do the
people's work here he's like he's like
sushi uh people like do you ever want to
if I told you you can eat cheap sushi
would you want that and he's like no and
he's like you know he's like so just
like the you know wine industry uh
people buy expensive things because it
makes them feel good that they bought a
higher quality thing so he goes just
test the price so we did it we basically
upped the price 50 on one menu versus
the other we just a b tested it and we
had like higher conversion rate on the
higher price which is crazy um like not
even just it netted more money it was
higher conversion rate on the higher
price so that was like the first time I
saw this like menu a b testing I mean
think about how big of a lift that is
like if you can convert every customer
at a higher rate at a higher dollar
amount that's like you know meaningful
in an industry that's like 10 margins
and so we did that then we tested other
things like
uh instead of just saying you know this
is a whatever this is like the
Philadelphia roll we use salmon it's
like Alaskan salmon
hand caught Alaskan cinnamon farm caught
hand hand you know handled Alaskan
salmon or whatever we just started
adding all these extra words that were
like nothing change nothing they were
all true but it's like always fresh
never Frozen Alaskan salmon hand caught
by a farmer near you and it's like oh
people like love that and then they
would buy more and so you could see
these little menu tricks now what I
didn't think of which is your your
genius idea is how do you actually turn
that into a business where you could
become an agency that does this for
companies you could become a piece of
software that does this as AV testing of
QR codes
um you could do this with physical menus
also by the way like you could just give
out two different versions of the
physical menu and say and just track the
tickets and be like cool we know what
the what the checkout is for both
um for how much they spend on both sides
and we can just prove to you that menu
design a is better than b and like you
know your current menu was designed by
like your niece who knows Photoshop so
like you know I think we can do better
than that and if we do that if we beat
your current menu then you pay us you
know 50 a month and we'll keep running
tests for you yeah I think this is
actually a really really great idea
yeah I think the key difference I mean
you always look for inflection points I
think you guys say or changes and so
before you're right you could do this
with physical menus but you know the
data is so much harder to get and you
have to like match up the physical menu
with the POs software you're using but
now I don't know what the percentage is
but we all know a ton of restaurants are
using these QR codes and so they're
already they've like taken the major
step that they went before of digitizing
the experience and so now what you need
to do is just apply those analytics and
so some company needs to just go create
the software ideally it integrates into
the POS so you just literally can
pop out a report at the end but even if
you don't have it integrating with the
POs I think you can even just like look
at oh how long does someone spend on
this menu versus this menu how are they
scrolling yeah what items are being sold
I don't think you would even need to
because you're basically so basically
they'll scan the QR code and it's like
you know Google optimize or optimizing
one of those they'll enter an ABS
exactly and then you're gonna pass the
the final value Here's the final cart
that they're checking out with to the
you know to to the thing and when it's
in person uh like in restaurant like
they check out uh with everything you
know they don't they don't like they
don't walk away you know they actually
do order food so you can kind of like
bet pretty heavily on that I wonder if
people would also do this with uh
doordash or ubereats like yeah could I
be a service that just optimizes your
doordash listing with photos menus copy
and like if you're a national chain
that's in like you know whatever
thousand cities and I can get you an
extra half a point conversion or extra
two dollar you know cart size that's
pretty meaningful for for these uh you
know these restaurants that are on on
these delivery platforms yeah I was
thinking about that too because ubereats
menus are always so long and you know
there's like that what's it called where
you have too many options
um paralysis by analysis or whatever
exactly exactly yeah and also ubereats
will have three or so items at the top
of like our most popular items and I
don't know if Uber actually selects that
for the restaurant but if you had the
option and actually if you're an
engineer at Uber working on this like
create a platform where people can a B
test right on ubereats so that they feel
like that's a platform where they're
making more money versus doordash versus
their own like that's a value add passed
if someone created their own online menu
that people ordered from uh which would
make obviously more sticky for people to
stay there well I looked at the startup
that was I know this works because I
looked at the startup I was doing
exactly this what they were doing was
they would go to a local mom-and-pop
restaurant that was like let's say
Chinese food they'd say great you know
Mr Hans Chinese you know great you're
you're everybody loves you locally
and now you're on doordash but like your
photos are kind of crap your you know
your descriptions are all off you're not
saying what foods are vegan even though
they are vegan you're just you don't
list them
um like you're just not optimized so
what he would do is he would partner
with the restaurant and he would just
create a shadow like a like a clone of
the brand but he would call it like
you know um like choo choo Chinese like
it would be like a more like catchy name
the all the photos are super bright
um so it's like you know on a backdrop
of like orange or red or whatever and
like really good looking photos and they
would trim the menu down he'd be like
look people come in here they want like
fried chicken and they want dumplings
and they want this and that and so he
would just do like this is just these
items
um he wrote better copy he took better
photos and then all it was was when an
order gets placed on those restaurants
that same restaurant just gets a ticket
they don't even it's like they don't
even know it's like from this other
brand basically and then later they
would send them packaging that's like
hey if it comes in through this Regis
this like uh ticket printer
um put it in the choo choo Chinese like
box don't put it in Mr Hans like you
know like local box
um and so they just create a separate
packaging so he's like yeah we have 200
restaurants we do like you know 17
million in gmv and we operate none of
these restaurants they were already
restaurants that already existed all we
did was just Rebrand them for Postmates
and ubereats and doordash and I was like
oh my God like this is like a
mind-blowing idea that yeah actually
works he's like yeah they love it
because they get like 30 extra Revenue
just because we're better at marketing
on those platforms than they are and um
I wonder how they do it now I actually
haven't caught up with them I didn't I
didn't end up investing because I was
like
I don't know where this goes like this I
feel like this could just get like
banned or blocked in one second but like
uh it was a fascinating idea and that
guy was really talented who was doing it
yeah uh one more thing on the idea of
food have you seen that I think it's the
FDA their food pyramid or at least in
Canada that's what we called it the food
pyramid and you have like all these
grains and they're like eat this much
bread and and they're rethinking that
have you seen that they're they're
really well they should right
carbs the foundation
like fruit was this time fruit and
vegetables were this like they shared a
little section like they had bunk beds
at the top of the pyramid it was crazy
yeah they were uh you know people got
upset because I mean a simple example is
they'd be like nuts no nuts too much fat
and then they'd be like butt white bread
okay you know they're foundational and
so uh they're coming out with a new food
pyramid of sorts and that impacts I
didn't know this but foods can uh apply
the word healthy to their products like
you know Brands you could like actually
have the word healthy on your cereal box
as an example based on this food pyramid
or some sort of requisites and they're
changing that and I just thought I don't
know if there's a business idea here but
I feel like there's going to be a ton of
content a ton of changes coming out
because of this because I mean the food
pyramid was pretty foundational and so I
don't know what the business idea here
is but it's just like one of those uh
there's there's got to be something here
well that's a good inflection I'll give
you another inflection like that that I
was thinking about over the weekend
um so you know like the law change that
allows College athletes to monetize
their brand or face called nil name and
like this and um so that came into
effect this year and so now now College
athletes can get paid for example when
we did our MFM camp we paid uh puff
Johnson this basketball player at North
Carolina to come like drop in and play
pickup with us it was just a cool moment
it's like oh yeah here's like this guy
who's gonna be in the NBA in a couple
years like he's just he's just playing
with us and we paid him I don't even
know what like 200 or something like
that to show up for for an hour and he's
like cool like I got nothing else going
on on a Saturday like I'll go pick up
200 bucks and by the way he was an
awesome guy
um so that's a little like Market that's
gotten created I was like I was asking
Ben I was like how did you book him like
what'd you use and he's like I just dm'd
him on Instagram
and I was like oh interesting there's no
there's not really a great Marketplace
yet that's connecting College athletes
to the like people who want to pay them
for their you know just to to do an
appearance or a sponsorship whatever
there's some people trying but nobody's
like don't know there's going to be one
company that just owns this
here's the liquidity it's like we got
all the athletes and then like because
of that we got all the brands and we
take care of all the transactions and
you don't need to use Instagram DMS and
like venmo like it just all happens to
your platform and we have all the
reporting that we hand over to the
universities so I think that's like a
big idea is like create Angel list for
like you know the nil Marketplace the
second thing is just
what opportunities does this open up so
Dave Portnoy who runs Barstool they
jumped on this pretty early they're like
oh great we'll have a Barstool athlete
program where you can sign up to be a
Barstool athlete which will help you get
these deals and uh they came out they're
like we're taking zero percent cut on
these deals I don't know how or why but
they just decided to say that and
um and he's like we have 200 000 College
athletes as part of this now some some
like huge number like that that's insane
so I was thinking I was like man so many
different products and brands have been
built off influencer marketing
everything from you know movement
watches which were like early to
Instagram like influencer marketing and
built 100 million dollar watch brand
um you know Sugar Bear Hair you know
they got the Kardashians to be take
pictures with this gummy you know biting
this little blue gummy and that became
like this iconic look and then that
became like again 100 million dollar
like you know uh supplements brand and
so now I'm thinking well all of a sudden
overnight you now can tap into the
influencer marketing of college athletes
across the country
and probably very few brands are doing
this just yet and you could almost
create a company just working backwards
from
all right if I could get every
influential College athlete to post
something
what product should I make that's going
to work best with their audience and
like their trust and all that stuff
because it's kind of an unsaturated
marketing channel right now in an
unsaturated marketing channel right now
is like worth it can be worth like 100
million dollars if you can if you can be
the first to figure it out that debt
platform and so you could kind of think
about what products would Their audience
buy because now I can reach them for a
very low cost and they this couldn't
this literally couldn't happen before so
you have this inflection change and so I
think that's another like brainstorm
that somebody could do and figure out
what product would fit that category and
just work backwards from the
distribution
what would you do do you have any
thoughts on if you were to choose that
as your Channel people talk about like
Channel Market but what what product
would you create
well so so thinking on the Eco like kind
of the e-commerce side just for a second
so I was like all right you can uh and I
don't know if eCommerce is the best like
I think probably like some credit card
or debit card or something like that is
probably the best like if you could
basically go get you know
um a million people A million college
students to start using your credit card
because you got you know 100 000
athletes to just say like oh I'm using
this and sign up for this bonus Point
program and you get a you know whatever
500 credit for spring break or whatever
I don't know you could come up with some
offer but you distribute it through
these athletes and you basically say
cool if I if I get at age 18 to 21
somebody to pick my credit card what's
that Worth to me
um and I think that's probably like you
know one of the best categories you
could be in but if it's not that let's
just take e-commerce for a second like I
think that you want the you find that
you would first go to the class of the
best e-commerce products to like high
purchase rate high like kind of lock-in
basically high margin
um you know low shipping why like native
deodorant was such a great product it
weighed less than a pound so you could
ship it in a normal envelope so shipping
was low cost it's repurchased because
you wear deodorant every day and you run
out of it every whatever two three
months and so you're gonna keep buying
in
um it's high margin like it only costs
this much to make and they could charge
whatever 20 bucks to to sell a two pack
and so like
it had a lot of the traits that make for
a great product and so I would try to
figure out like whether it's like
protein powder or like athletic greens
or you know like some you know like
sparkling water brand or like you know
some Seltzer smelly water oh yeah smelly
water I try to figure out some product
like that that's like Mass Appeal high
margin High repeat purchase rate and
then I would just like work backwards
from that and I wouldn't do you know
products that are like you know big
one-off purchases with the low
repurchase I just try to stay away from
those so I would go look at the winners
of like current e-commerce and then I
would try to you know retrofit those and
be like would that like particularly hit
with a um a college ground like I think
like an energy drink would be like
amazing uh like I think I think if you
could do like you know whatever Red Bull
rock star type of thing is if you could
just make like the next the next either
you know um vitamin water or or energy
drink I think that's probably the the
strongest one but if it's not that then
some kind of like subscription product
like maybe deodorant or um I don't know
something like that this is probably
where I'd go for it deodorant would work
you can be like don't smell on the court
or some you know cheesy thing like that
but yeah I think deodorant would
actually be well you could also like
just if it's like just riffing on that
you could take the deodorant Brands and
you could like make it specific you
could make the sense specific to the to
the campus so like you know whatever
whatever the name like you know you have
like Longhorn you know whatever for UT
and then you have like the names of the
scents that like kind of fit that market
it's the same scent you're just labeling
it differently depending on where it's
at but you're now pulling into that kind
of like brand Affinity they already have
with their with their campus or whatever
else and it makes sense for the athlete
to be promoting that because it's like
again they're like a college athlete for
that school maybe you could do some
things like that to like juice how um
you know how attractive it is
I kind of love that because I I'm just
you know my marketing hat is on and
there's so many taglines you could be
like sniff out your competitors or like
you know you you could imagine these
internet Wars of like oh man that like
that University is sent sucks or that
like high school like have you smelt
that like that that stuff's nasty or
like you know people actually competing
on which which college has you know for
every every stick that's bought here we
you know drop one stink bomb at your
rival school like that's like some some
way to like you know compete with the
other schools nice
I can't find this client info have you
heard of HubSpot HubSpot is a CRM
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out of sync spreadsheets or
dueling databases HubSpot grow better
okay let's do a quick one which is I
actually saw this in the trends
newsletter a while ago I didn't write
this but
um it was the stat which is the average
person spends one and a half thousand
dollars after a breakup I have no idea
where the stack came from but
definitely got the wheel spinning and
they came up with a bunch of different
ideas which I think actually are getting
some traction divorce party ideas is
something that gets search volume
breakup cake
um people throwing their own breakup
parties and I was just like huh I don't
know if there's you know specific brands
that are taking this on but I was like
huh that that's that one and a half
thousand dollars don't know where it
came from but there's something there
that's like if I'm if I'm F Jerry you
know that like Instagram account and
they have these like they built a kind
of like a little media Empire they have
a bunch of other accounts but they also
have products they make like they made
that that card game I think they they
make some products yeah if I was if I
was one of those accounts I would be
jumping on this I would basically say
all right it's already viral it's meme
worthy it's it's remarkable people are
gonna talk about this so how do I make
you know like the best breakup cake
delivery service or yes um you know like
uh the Revenge body kit and it's like
you know we send you this like the seven
day detox
um where you said you're like a healing
Crystal we send you like a juice cleanse
and whatever else to like you know get
that person out of your out of your life
so you're gonna get the bad juju you
know away and I'd be like you know this
is called bad juju or whatever and I
would just try to create like a viral
product through that
um because I think it's on brand and I
think it has like enough demand where
there's you could see this doing you
know two to ten million dollars a year
all organic yeah just because the
product is so viral
um you know it's probably not going to
be enormous but there's a there's enough
of a niche there especially if you're
one of these accounts because you
already got distribution or you're
somebody who goes to those accounts and
partners with them and says hey I got
the right product for you guys let's do
you know some kind of profit share and
I'll run this business and you guys just
help me promote this like you know uh
whatever like the breakup vodka and it's
like you know this is the break of vodka
kit or whatever you know whatever the
thing is
yeah I mean I'm imagining you know all
the tropes of someone gets broken up
with and they become super fit and like
they get a PhD and they just become like
the best version of themselves after the
breakup doesn't always happen but you
could imagine something like that even
less work it's like what's those what
are those like voodoo dolls where you
like poke it and you're like you know
you're just sending like ill will
towards them you could just like upload
a photo of your person we print you a
doll that looks like you know like close
enough like them and like you can do
that
that reminds me of did you see that
startup empty it was fake did you did
you hear about this it's I think it was
you know it had the silly spelling to it
was like e-m-p-t-i or something and it
was a fake startup that people thought
was real and basically they sent people
these empty boxes
um and the whole idea was like look we
send you these empty boxes and there's
some like motivational quote from Buddha
in it and it's like you know rid
yourself of all the things you don't
need in your life and the idea is that
people are supposed to take all their
junk put it in these boxes and send it
to this company for free but they pay
this company to send them these boxes
um but it was a fake startup and all
these people are writing about it
they're like oh this is so smart like
what a cool company
yeah exactly it was a joke but yeah
actually you could do that with this too
you could send them the breakup box it's
like put all their crap in this all
their crap they've left in your house
that reminds you of them put it in this
send it to us and we will send you a
video of us like burning this box in
this like epic way and like you get to
have that at the end that's it those are
the types of ideas you could do with
this nice so you were right before we
started reporting you were starting to
tell me you go here's my theory of why
people like this podcast and what is
your theory okay so there are many
reasons to love my first million I think
there's something that you guys have
done especially recently when you and
Sam just go back and forth and you tell
a really funny joke and then Sam just
starts laughing hysterically like in a
contagious way that most people would
hold back maybe on a podcast but it's
it's literally as people say like you're
in the room with him and it reminded me
of this subreddit I found recently
called r slash contagious laughter 4.5
million people subscribe to this and
it's one of I think the top hundreds
subreddits out there and it's literally
just a feed of people laughing and
there's there's dozens of posts every
day and I I was just as I went down it I
was like there's gotta be a post of Sam
and Sean
well okay let me tell you a couple
interesting things about this first I
think this must I think the subreddit
must be kind of like almost like new or
growing faster recently right because I
hadn't heard of this subreddit before
and I kind of keep an eye on on the top
ones but maybe I just missed it but I
I've also seen this trend on Tick Tock I
don't know if you've seen it somebody
will be like I'm a clinical psychologist
and I can make you happier in the next
10 seconds
repeat after me huh and there's like a
duet so that guy's like hot excuse like
haha
and you're just like okay I see where
this is going and then she just gets
like haha and like by the end both
people are just cracking up like because
it's like 10 Deep and uh you can't help
yourself like the body will just start
like genuinely laughing just from making
the sound like it goes both ways it's
not like something funny happens
therefore I break out laughing it's like
if you break out laughing intentionally
you could just like it could it's like
something funny just happened basically
and um yeah and so I've thought about
this like contagious laughter thing in
two ways one is as if I was thinking
about the podcast and I was like
I was watching I was watching the all
land pod
and um I love that podcast but they do
something that really bothers me which
is one of them will crack a joke and the
other guys don't what I call Selva joke
like they don't laugh
um and I don't know if they don't laugh
because they're trying to they're a they
don't think it's funny B it's not that
they're trying to keep it serious or see
they might just edit it where they just
don't use the audio track from someone
because it kind of makes it a little
choppy because you're using one on top
of the other
but it totally changes the vibe of
something when um in a podcast
especially when the other person
actually sells your joke like if you if
you try to crack something and I go with
it or and this works for for other
things on my first million too I call it
the homie move where Sam would be like
do you know how many people buy this
thing and I know it's probably a high
number if he's telling me like that but
I'll be like I don't know what like like
100 and just to give them they're like
no dude a million and like I give them
that like assist basically and so there
are several things like that where you
got to kind of sell the other person's
thing and it's not fake it's just like
be expressive like laugh hard react big
that stuff works when it comes to
content and people are very shelled up
about that sort of thing
um I don't know if that that is in line
with what you're talking about totally
one of the funniest moments on my first
million was your Orlando Bloom story
which I think if I just heard you
telling it by yourself I'd be like yeah
that's pretty funny but Sam's laughter
layered onto that where he was you could
just tell he was dying as you were
telling that story just made it honestly
top five moments on my first million
history for me but that's why I think
this subreddit is so great even in their
rules or their like Community guidelines
you know how someone posts something and
there's typically a bot that says hey
report this if X Y and Z on that
subreddit it's like report this if
you're laughing at a joke or some sort
of incident and not the laughter
specifically they're like we only want
you to be on here to hear other people
laughing so I don't know I just thought
that was like a fun a fun thing and
reminded me of why I think some people
love my first million it's just so
authentic well you're you're about to do
a podcast and do you remember what I
told you my advice to you when it came
to to doing a podcast I don't know if
you remember this this is a couple years
ago now I actually don't you should tell
me I was like
um don't be too normal or I was like
you're too normal I was like you need to
be um yeah like to me the ideal podcast
guest is like half insane
um and what that means is like there's
things that they're not even aware of
that are inside like Sam has a ton of
these where he's like dude I was
thinking you know you know you think
about like what happens if someone
broken right behind me right now and
tried to kill me I'm like no I don't
think that the fact that you think I
think that means you're kind of insane
like you're not even aware of that
that's a weird thing you're doing you
think that other people do that too and
then the second is like being willing to
say something crazy stuff like that uh
and then the third is like they don't
hedge um
and like try to downplay like most
people are basically taking their own
little volume knob and turning it down
all the time just because they want to
fit in and so the best thing you could
do if you want to be a personality on
the Internet is like you can't have that
I'm trying to fit in turn the volume
down thing you gotta like turn it up if
anything
um and so that was my theory on it now I
do think I might be wrong because like
there's people like Lex Friedman or
whoever who are successful with their
podcast and like you know it's like you
know Lex is not you know his volume is
like down to two basically he's a very
monotone
calm normal person and people people do
end up loving it so I don't think my
theory was was entirely correct but I do
think it helped to have like you know a
bit of a screw loose and like you know
you're a very stable smart person you
don't have that much of a screw loose I
think you're almost playing from behind
uh when it comes to internet content no
I think you're right I so in preparing
for every episode that I do I go and
listen to that person on other podcasts
and it's crazy how they get asked exact
same questions everywhere they go
because there's just kind of a template
of like okay so tell me about your life
like tell me why you went this direction
in your career and I think you've even
talked about this on my first million
you're like we don't do that we we
ignore all the questions that we know
everyone's gonna ask I guess maybe some
people want to hear but we ask you like
the real stuff like how much do you make
like what keeps you up at night like
when have you failed or like even more
than that you actually just ask the
questions that people probably want to
hear yeah there's this there's this
great thing that happens if you always
ask questions like that you it's like a
get out of jail free card it's like well
that's just what he does versus if you
just try to Spring that on one person
it's something like Whoa it's a little
intrusive there but it's like oh that's
just stick that's this that's the show
stick like that's what they do
um then you can get away with being a
little more blunt and so uh you know
cultivating like an image of being you
know sort of a don't give an f slash
blunt personality has all these
advantages because people just create
new rules for you they're like ah you
know if a normal person did this yeah I
would feel wrong but that's that's just
Sean being Sean that's just Sam being
Sam man you're like whoa okay
I just get to be that uh that's awesome
that is awesome wow okay that's good
let's keep going what else you got
cheating scandals everyone's talking
about it chess poker fishing I even saw
Irish dance in a newsletter recently so
every you know cheating's everywhere but
uh well if people are out of the loop
frame it frame it for them about what
what other controversy these okay so I
don't know all of them in depth but I've
been following the chess one pretty
closely Magnus Carlsen World chess
champion played Hans Neiman several
weeks ago uh Neiman beat him but then
there was all this controversy after
where Magnus was acting sketchy and then
eventually came out with this statement
saying hey I believe Hans cheated I
can't speak to exactly why and then
there has been a history of Hans
cheating in the past as well so there's
all of these people on the internet who
are taking sides and saying no Hans has
been really good how could you cheat
over the board and then there's people
who believe in Carlson and are like no
he's had a history of cheating we just
don't know how and then there's been a
similar poker controversy and then a
fishing one where they were stuffing
fish with like lead balls and so I think
a bunch of people have just you know
become fascinated with this idea that oh
my gosh people are cheating even though
they have been for a long time but um I
have a couple ideas around the idea of
cheating but I first want to hear your
take like what do you think about these
cheating scandals well there's something
very seductive about them I don't know
about you but like I don't follow chess
normally but when it came to this I was
like God damn it if I don't have to get
to the bottom of this like you know here
goes four hours of like YouTube rabbit
holding to figure out and I don't it's
not even like it's a better entry point
for me than just this person is great or
this was a great match it's like here's
the controversy oh what is it right and
it goes back to this thing that uh I
remember Dana White said once Dana
White's the president of the UFC and he
goes
I go they were like you know UFC is kind
of the syringe small thing but you're
saying it's going to be huge why do you
believe that he goes I believe that
because if you go to a park or a
playground right now
and you've got a basketball court people
are playing basketball you got a
football field people playing football
you soccer over here baseball over there
and then somebody screams fights and
there's a fight going on guess where
everybody's head's turning to the fight
and that was his whole thesis of like
why I think the UFC is going to be big
because fighting is this Universal
Universal thing that just gets you to
turn your neck whether you wanted to or
not and it's actually kind of played out
the UFC's become This Global sport you
know a five billion dollar plus company
and um and it succeeded in places where
you know like football doesn't really
translate into Europe or Asia but
fighting does fighting you know like
there's Chinese the Chinese viewership
is big in the UFC so is Russian and so
is you know wherever every little
country so
I think controversy is kind of the same
thing uh where like I wasn't that into
chess until I found out that there might
be this like Scandal what's the Scandal
I gotta know and um and then you look at
the evidence and you're like well
there's two kind of like interesting
components one is like how did how would
somebody cheat that's kind of
interesting it's sort of like a Ocean's
Eleven like how did they rob the bank
type of thing uh because you know you're
sitting there at a chessboard it's not
online so you know this guy had been he
had been caught cheating online admitted
to cheating online and many people cheat
online they basically have a program
running because you know AI can play
chess better than a human can
um but then you have how is he cheating
over the board and there was this then
somebody threw out this crazy uh Theory
which was that the anal beads yeah he's
got anal beads you know basically up his
butt that vibrate and tell him you know
what to what move to make or whatever
and so I and and the way that Magnus did
it kind of added to it so he first when
he got beat it was big news because
Magnus is the greatest player in the
world maybe the greatest player of all
time
he then goes online and he tweets out
this thing like
um he tweet out like a meme or a quote
from a soccer coach it was like you know
I can't if I say what I want to say I'll
get in trouble and people are like what
is he trying to say
then he comes out with a statement
saying I think he cheated then he plays
him again and one move or two moves into
the match he just uh resigns he
basically quits and walks away
um again sort of like saying I'm not
gonna play with this cheater and um and
so some people are like is this just
sour grapes and other people are like no
he knows something but he's not said why
he thinks he's cheating yet and then
over probably because he doesn't know
right well like I don't think that he
thinks that Hans cheated but he doesn't
know how and that's probably why he
hasn't been descriptive about it because
he's like I think this guy's cheated
there's two pieces of evidence one is
just he says
he didn't look like he was trying like
the guy beat me I'm the greatest player
in the world and I know what it looks
like when people try to beat me they're
very focused and concentrated he barely
looked like he was paying attention yet
he played basically a perfect game in BP
that was his first thing was just like I
didn't feel like he tried and he beat me
um so that was the first piece of
evidence and the second was people went
back and looked at all of his like past
games as he ranked up because he's had
like this crazy rise from like you know
a normal great player to like Grand
Master or whatever top ranked player and
they and they did this thing where they
basically can put your game history back
in this like chess solver engine and see
how close to perfect how close to AI did
you play and like the greatest players
of all time have played like at 62 or 72
percent of their moves matched you know
like what the AI would do like perfect
moves and he's had like several mini
games where he's at 100 and like the
greatest players ever will have like no
games at 100 during their like rise to
the top and so it's sort of fishy on
that front like you know really this
guy's making like 100 Game Theory
optimal moves uh and the greatest
players ever at best are like at 70 and
so that those are the kind of pieces of
evidence against him but still nobody
knows how he did it if he if he is
indeed cheating
yeah exactly so I used to play chess
competitively as a kid and both of those
are very compelling arguments the first
one especially like if you've ever
played chess across the board if you're
in a tough situation certainly if you're
playing the world chess champion you are
concentrating so hard I think there's
stats that say like you know a full
chess match can burn like a thousand
calories or whatever if you're sitting
at the board for several hours and so I
think that's really compelling my
question is a how do you prove that
someone's cheating I don't know if you
can I think you can prove someone has
the intent to cheat if you catch them
with like yeah some anal beads or
something in their shoe but how do you
actually prove that someone has cheated
and then I'm also curious to know how
these you know like the Chess Federation
Etc how are they going to change the way
they operate to catch the shooting in
the future I don't I don't know I guess
they make people walk through a metal
detector but
um
right yeah you can always do that yeah
exactly like and I'm not going to get
caught once you know it's just like you
know in the Olympics you have you saw or
wada who basically the agencies that are
supposed to catch you from doping but
what happens is
guys go to the Olympics they test clean
they break all the records and oh
they're a natural athlete and then six
years later wada updates their tests so
they can test for new stuff uh that's
new to them but the athlete had it all
along and then they go back to Tesla
samples and they're like oh turns out
they were doping right and this has
happened like a few times in in the
Olympics and in High Level Sports And so
there's this problem of like it's this
cat and mouse game between cheaters and
the in the and the sort of like the
anti-cheat but anti-cheat is actually a
really interesting business-like
category so I didn't really know much
about this until we started building a
startup that was in the gaming space
this was the company that ended up
getting acquired by twitch but when we
were building in the space we would play
games in the office just for fun we'd
play fortnite played OverWatch played a
bunch of bunch of different games like
that and um
and then you you sort of see two things
one is like wow the importance of like
um this sort of hand-eye coordination
aim basically being able to aim and
shoot uh in these games is like critical
and then there's like you'll play
somebody and you're like oh my God like
as soon as I peek around the corner boom
I get headshot immediately perfectly one
time every time by the same guy and it's
like oh it's an Aimbot it's like
basically somebody's using a basically
like a piece of software that will
automatically just aim for your head
every single time more than a human can
do and so then the games have all these
anti-cheat mechanisms built in to
prevent that because it's I mean it
ruins the game when you have uh when you
have cheaters and so at the highest
levels and these games now have like a
really big competitive scene Esports
like they have to figure out how to
catch this and so you have a software
game and then you have software
anti-cheap which is different than like
the Olympics or this like chest metal
detector thing where it's a it's an
offline game now you do offline offline
anti-cheat and so I think that the
offline world needs to sort of learn
more from the gaming World about anti
cheat because there's these companies
that are quite big that are anti-cheat
providers to all games because each game
individually can't build the security
system that's going to stop every you
know potential form of cheating and so
there's just individual companies that
are like we are anti-cheat software
every game becomes our customer and we
can use them and so I think that's
what's gonna have to happen which is
that you're going to have to have like
anti-cheat companies that are security
systems basically for the for the
competitive Integrity of the games and I
think chess and poker and you know
fishing and others are going to have to
like ramp up in this area
um But the irony is this is the best
thing that's ever happened to us best
thing since Queen's Gambit right more
attention than ever uh on these things
yeah I mean there's like conspiracy
theories which is like Huns and Magnus
are in this together and like they're
they're associated with chess.com and
they're all doing this to just like hype
up chess which I don't think is true but
I mean it's kind of crazy when you think
about fishing for example how was the
fact that there was lead balls in a fish
not caught earlier I mean I think you're
right that some of these in-person
sports are just like way behind on the
concept of cheating which is ancient uh
so I'm interested to see how that
progresses but one idea um like you said
there's gonna be this wave of measures
that needs to be put in place and I just
thought of this this thing that I saw
you guys have had Peter levels on the
podcast before and he had so Nomad list
is one of his companies and for ages
people kept trying to copy Nomad list
there was all these companies were like
we're gonna hire 10 engineers and we're
gonna just like smash you right because
you're one engineer and and we're just
gonna take all your data and he would
just for fun uh put in fake data so
there was this country or city that he
put in called dorobo and he would just
do that to be like who copied my data
set just to see which I kind of loved
and I am I was trying to think through
how that maybe could be applied
elsewhere I don't know if it could be
applied to chess but you could imagine
like what if stockfish just had just had
like a couple incorrect moves right that
would catch the cheater it's like oh you
played G4 you were not supposed to play
G4 if you were a great player you would
know otherwise and I just wonder what
other kind of
spoofs or like tricks you could put in
as anti-cheating measures well I don't
know if you saw this uh I was looking at
I was on Twitter this morning and I saw
that Elon had tweeted um at somebody
this story as that was pretty
interesting so somebody tweeted at Elon
they go hey Elon back in the day you had
this 2008 I think there was somebody who
was leaking internal company data and um
they kept leaking into news outlets it
was bad for business and then you found
them uh I'm curious how did you find
them when it when it had happened and he
goes actually it's an interesting story
because normally elon's tweets are just
memes but he's like actually it's an
interesting story we sent everybody in
the company the same email but with one
slightly different space somewhere in
the email
um so like we would you know between
this period we would either do two
spaces or one space but we it was a long
email so we were able to create like a
unique fingerprint for everybody in the
company we sent them all a slightly
unique uh email that was like sort of
like binary proof that this was your
email that got out and it's like so we
found the person that way you know we
caught them sort of immediately it was
the fastest path to catching them versus
going through all the email like servers
and like patting people down as they
leave the the leave the factory like how
are we gonna find this person and that
was the best way to do it was to put out
something juicy that was false space out
the thing differently and then they
caught the person immediately and he's
like you know that we we you know we
asked them to pursue a career in another
company and like a way of saying it yeah
that's so clever yeah so I'm interested
to see how this progresses because I do
Wonder it's like who who wins did the
cheaters win do the anti-cheating
measures win historically I mean in
gaming what was the case like could the
anti-cheating measures keep up with the
cheaters no like the the best cheater is
always one step ahead because you know
there's always a the bigger the more
money involved the bigger the incentive
to cheat and so you're anytime you have
a big pot of money you're gonna find
people are going to cheat this is why
you know PayPal and Facebook and others
they they have so much so much staff
every day dedicated just to catching
cheers and um because there's a huge
amount of money involved in it this is
why people love Bitcoin they're like wow
if somebody could have hacked this or
spoofed this or done a double spend
there is a literally like half a
trillion dollar prize for the taking and
because it hasn't that just shows you
how secure this is so it's like the
absence of a hack shows a security and
so with with anywhere there's a lot of
money there's going to be an incentive
to cheat and there's always the hardest
part is that it's usually not
sophisticated so for example in the if
you followed the poker one that's been
going on it's like this
that this uh like high stakes game in La
that they stream the game and so they
have like a twitch Channel or whatever
where they're streaming the game so it's
like kind of like the World Series of
Poker but just going on all the time
people are playing for like each person
has like 100 or 300 000 on the table so
you get these pots and like half a
million dollar pots and this girl makes
this This Woman's playing this hand and
she plays it in a way that kind of makes
no sense she has Jack four off suits and
doesn't make any sense why you would
even be in the hand uh the board has no
Jacks no fours and it has a flush draw
has a straight draw the other guy has
both and he Betsy bats she you know she
calls it all in when she has nothing and
she wins the hand
and people are like there is no way you
could make that call like there's no
you're holding those cards the only
explanation is you looked at your cards
wrong and you thought you had something
else but she kind of like if you read
the audio is there too where she's like
no I don't have it right she's basically
saying I don't have uh they're like do
you have a three she's like no I don't
have a three
um and so she's basically she's like oh
you know I just did this as a bluff
catcher and literally the guy's face
when she calls at first he's like oh you
got me I didn't have it you caught my
bluff but then she turns over her cards
and he's like okay you caught my bluff
but you caught my bluff with that that
makes
zero sense that you would ever try to
even catch a bluff with that and he's
literally stone-faced for like a minute
and a half he doesn't say anything
he's just looking and his eyes are just
moving between the table and her and
he's like you could tell the computer
and his brain is like breaking it's like
there's no way this could have happened
he is detected basically in an anomaly
and a an anomalous move that has to be
something like cheating like there's no
other explanation it's not about how
somebody could make you know a 200 000
bet on with those cards unless you knew
what my cards were and what's coming out
and so um and so they like launched this
investigation and like I think Reddit
and YouTube are great at that where they
like crowdsourced the investigation
they're like finding old clips and
they're like more than any police
officer could do you know put Reddit on
the case like when they found the Boston
Bomber or whatever I don't know if that
ended up being true or not but like it's
the same idea and so they're showing
basically what it looks like happened
was just there's a human input in the
production team who was probably feeding
her the information and she had like a
vibrator device on her like in her
pocket or in her pants or something like
that
um that was like signaling her just like
if it vibrates that means you're good uh
like call the bet if it doesn't vibrate
that means you don't have you're not
winning full and um that's what people
think is the like sort of most likely
explanation for this at this point but
that's hard because it's human
engineering and like
um there's this conference that happens
every year I forgot the name of it but
you might know it's in Vegas and it's
like the hacker conference I don't know
if you've heard it's like Defcon or
something like that it's like oh that's
familiar yeah it's basically it's the
number one like hackercon hacker
convention like you know like I don't
know why anybody would go to this it's
like you know walking into a you know a
shark Den basically but one thing that
they showed like I kind of went down
this Rabbit Hole of like what what do
they talk about at this thing and one
thing they showed is just how much of
like hacks is not like brilliant
Computer Engineering it's somebody just
calling you and being like hey I'm just
verifying some information with the bank
here could you just tell me your
mother's maiden name and your date of
birth and your last four of your Social
all right thank you you're confirmed
nothing else to worry about and then
they just take that and they call the
bank and they say hey I need to change
my password can you change it for me I
forgot what my old one is but you know
oh my security questions yeah my
mother's maiden name is this and here's
my last four and then they get the
password change to take all your money
and they didn't hack in the system they
just literally like they catfished you
right they sort of like uh the you know
human engineering they basically just
like
trick you into giving up information and
that's how a lot of the big hacks happen
is they just trick a human into giving
them their password and then they don't
need to break in it's like you gave me
the keys I can just walk right in
exactly that's why Sim swapping is like
one of the unfortunately super common
ways of hacking people because people
will just go into like an ATT and be
like hey I'm this person this is my
phone number I lost my sim could you
give me a new one and they just get that
um and so yeah it's it definitely humans
are the like faulty piece there's a
great business that came out of this
Insight which was there's many of them
now but but when I heard this I remember
thinking oh my God that is a genius it's
basically a business that goes to
companies and they say hey
the number you know that 90 of these
hacks happen just because your your
employee is going to just type their
password on the wrong page and they're
like yeah I guess that's true yeah they
go so here's what we're gonna do we're
gonna send false phishing emails to your
employees and um but don't worry like
you know when they type it in we're just
gonna give you a report every month
because you're paying for a contract
which is just to say this employee click
this link and this would have been a
breach oh thankfully we caught it you
can now educate the employees better and
we you know this is a way to like you
know make sure that your your employees
are not going to fall for this and um
and those companies do extremely well
because it's way cheaper to like prevent
the hack that way just by having
somebody kind of stress test your
employees in that way try to break
through the system and just say hey here
is where we found a vulnerability and um
I thought that was just like a genius
business category to be in yeah I I have
a co-worker that fell for one of those
recently and she was like oh man I got
to do this training but I was like
really that's all we have to do we just
got to do a little bit of training like
this seems pretty faulty if all these
employees are clicking on this but I
kind of love the idea of ethical hacking
have you seen there's been someone
recently I think their their code name
or their hacker name is like bjorkska or
something and they've hacked into three
of Indonesia's like large government
databases and at first people were like
oh man this is just Indonesia is a huge
country right in terms of population
they're like oh they've got like
Millions hundreds of millions of Records
the first time and then the second time
they were like oh my gosh this happened
again like this person has way too much
data but by the third time they were
like this person is just exposing how
fragile all of our systems are because
they haven't you know sent the data
anywhere they're just like you guys you
have to fix this and they're just like
using proof to show it instead of saying
you know going to people and tweeting
like our systems are really insecure or
whatever instead they're just like let
me just show you and I think it's uh I
mean I think have you heard of whiz I
think that's like enter some sort of
Enterprise security software uh it was
the fastest or at least one of the
fastest that hit 100 million ARR
recently like faster than deal faster
than a lot of the companies that we're
familiar with
yeah just Wiz right I think that's the
the name of it with Cloud security yeah
exactly yeah they had they came out with
some I've never heard of this company
it's like hey we're the fastest growing
company in the world
exactly
and they do is this what they do they do
the sort of like bug Bounty stuff yeah
100 million errors 18 months I don't
know exactly what they do but I just
know there's some sort of Enterprise
security software and uh yeah they're
like quietly the the biggest fastest
we're not the biggest the fastest
growing company in a while
yeah that's insane all right enough uh
enough hacking and cheating and stealing
uh although I do I just I love that
stuff I can't get enough I love the
controversy I know same let's do these
internet portfolios so I think these are
these are pretty cool I I think these
are good inspo for people and you've
curated a group of them let me just kind
of set it up which is basically
people have these kind of like
um personal websites portfolios and I
think you you wrote something on this
doc I want you to explain you wrote
evidence greater than greater than
greater than confidence uh so what is
that what does that mean and then why do
these interest you yeah so I think in
the age of social media especially it's
like really easy for you to be seen as
an expert in something you know someone
who's done no marketing can look up a
bunch of Wikipedia articles and start
tweeting threads on it and a bunch of
people who don't know any better can
just say oh wow this person has a lot of
confidence right and you know that's
fine
um but what I think is important
especially in this era where everyone
can seem like an expert is evidence of
evidence over confidence and what do I
mean by evidence it's like don't tell me
you're this business Expert show me the
businesses that you've built and how
successful they are and how you built
them or let me see how you built them
instead of you telling me how you built
them and I think one version of this for
individuals are these personal portfolio
sites so you know you can have a site
which again it's like I've written for
fortune and I have this many followers
on Twitter or you know all of these
things that you've made up that tell
people you're confident instead of how
about you just show me your skills and
some of these portfolios which will
hopefully pull up here
um are just really fascinating because
as soon as I go to them I'm like this
person is a badass I want to hire them
just based on what I see here based on
the evidence that they are a killer
Creator and so we should pull some of
them up but for example pull up this one
from Bruno Simon and tell me what you
see so basically it's Bruno hyphen
simon.com and you land and it's
literally a like Jeep that's on the
screen you hit the click Start there's a
Jeep that's on the screen and it says
use your keys to move around and it's
like and you just like you can you can
go forward and you can just like drive
into stuff it's like a 3D it's basically
a game uh and it's like his resume
almost but you can basically drive
around crash into stuff and like clearly
this person is like super talented
artist creative web developer type of
person it's like all right I'm gonna
drive to the projects section
um and like okay I'm in the project
section and I can see their different
things if I park my car on the open on
the parking spot there it'll open that
like you know
um that link to go see that website that
they built and this is amazing like this
is one of the best
portfolios I've ever seen like this is
like stunning yeah it's pretty awesome
pull up um another one which is just
another example click the one that says
interactive resume from Robbie Leonardi
so Robbie okay oh my God it's like
basically like a game of Mario so
there's a character and I'm scrolling
and all of a sudden I'm like okay level
one that's his about oh wow this is cool
um this is sick it's basically like a
chart of like oh I'm good at design
illustration whatever but it's like I'm
running through the level and I'm like
learning these different things about
the person about what they're into okay
NBA fan oh my God now I'm underwater I'm
doing the underwater level
yeah so this is crazy they basically
just took a resume designed it
beautifully and made it play like a
Mario Mario game and at the end of the
level it's like contact me here if you
want to work with me or whatever you
know here's my contact form you you've
won you've made it to the end of the
level you've won the thing I love about
this is I assume these people are not
applying for jobs but can you imagine if
you had a job opening and you had like a
hundred typical resumes of people being
like yeah I've worked here for three
years or I've done this I have this
degree and then one of them was this how
could you not hire this person how could
you so I made something like this when I
applied for so when I moved to Silicon
Valley I did this so basically I I
applied to two jobs when I wanted to
move to Silicon Valley I applied to
stripe and I applied to a place called
monkey Inferno stripe everybody knows
turned into like you know whatever 100
billion dollar company I would have been
like employee I don't know like 35 40 at
the time so it would have been great it
would have probably made like 10 30
million dollars something like that just
as like a mid-level
sales Biz Dev type guy that I was going
to join as unfortunately I crashed and
burned in the interview when he was like
sell me this pen and I was like uh and I
just fumbled
um but the uh the other job I applied to
is monkey Inferno and monkey Inferno was
a really cool company and one thing
that's interesting is the more
the company shows that they're unique
the more you sort of get the vibe and
you're like okay I can read the room
you're cool and unique and you
appreciate like a you know creativity
and a sense of humor so that's how I'm
gonna apply so I didn't send in a resume
I just made a website and I you know I
can't code I'm not like you're way more
technically talented let alone these
people who are like you know freaking
you know they're creating like you know
fake Mario game as their resume
but I made a basic website that was
basically and I just sent an email I
tried to copyright it while I was like
you know my first line of the email was
like
um you know uh hey Michael
um I'm applying for the I saw your role
for product manager
um and even though you know I have none
of the qualifications you're looking for
let me explain to you why I'm the man
for the job and like you know I think
that was like gonna get his attention to
read the next thing just to be like is
this guy you know a complete clown or
like is there something here and so I
wrote this email and I said you know I
rather than add a you know resume to the
stack of resumes like I made a website
for you and so I my my website wasn't
about me it was like why I should work
at Monkey Inferno so it was like more
tailored
um to him and I had these same things I
had this like uh skills chart but I
included stuff that I wasn't good at I
was like hard work I was like ah 40
percent like you know that was like one
of my lowest skills I was like I'm kind
of lazy actually
um you know I I'm kind of lazy I can't
force myself to do things that I don't
love to do but I gave them like things
and then in the interview like I
remember one of the guys was like why
would you apply for a job and write your
hard work is not high and I was like
well I'm glad you asked I can explain
here's here's what I think about that
and um and so I had this whole thing and
I kind of wrote a resume exactly for
them I was like you know here's some of
the my mottos here's like
I looked at your companies here's some
of the things I think I could do for
them and so I kind of tailored it to
that and I remember he later told me he
was like you know if you hadn't done
that website like there's no way we
would have hired you because
on paper you had like literally none of
the qualifications we were looking for
like the entire job description was like
just not you but
um that website was really cool it was
really unique nobody else had done
something like that and so it just made
me feel like we got to talk to this guy
and so that was like the the in that got
me got me the job in the in the in the
end yeah I mean I think I've hired a
decent amount now and there's so many
people who mass apply to jobs and
they're like yeah I'm interested in this
job and I have the qualifications but
the times I've been really impressed is
like you can tell someone really wants
to work there and has done their
research and you know the second they
get in you almost don't have to train
them on the company you probably have to
train them on other things but you know
they understand exactly what you're
trying to do because they've been
following your company or your team or
your people for a while
um so I think that's that's spot on
right let's do a couple of a couple of
these other ones so uh yeah let's rapid
fire through so the neil.fun one I think
I've talked about before on here this
one's awesome
um so it's n-e-a-l dot fun but I don't
think pull it up but basically it's like
it's just like the headline is a tiny
website on the internet and then he's
basically got a bunch of little like
interactive little projects that he's
made that you could do and I I remember
I went through the Absurd trolley
problems one
um which is basically like
if you remember in school where it's
like you know there's a train on the
tracks it's gonna you know kill five
people but you can pull the switch and
just kill this one would you do it and
you're like yeah I guess I'd rather kill
one than five I think I would do it and
then it basically like changes it to
like but the one is a baby would you do
it and you're like no I wouldn't kill
the baby and then it's like it's like
okay but the other one is five cats
would you do five cats and it's like it
just takes you through 30 like absurd
variations of that of that question and
each one when you say yes or no it says
74 of people agree with you 26 disagree
there's been 2.1 million votes of this
and you're like wow that's like that's
cool you can see where do you differ
from like you know the masses when it
comes to these things and so that's the
one I did are there any other cool ones
that he's got here
well I mean he has so many I'll call it
a couple so it feels like he just took
all of his Curiosities which are the
same Curiosities that many people have
and turn them into these yeah internet
games of sorts so one of them is like
explore the scale of space or um see who
was alive and next year you're like I
wonder who was alive in 1870 and you can
kind of see what um famous people or
influential people were alive at the
same time
um another one that's fun is the
internet's greatest debates so it's all
these questions like you know is it gif
or GIF or I can't remember what some of
the other ones are but he gets the
internet to vote on them
um so you actually you know you get the
answer to the internet's greatest
questions but as you can see if people
are watching on screen there's just so
many that he's built like this one that
was like design the next iPhone it just
lets you drag and drop like you can put
a camera in the like I put it like off
to the side like halfway off the camera
you could put an Android logo on it
um that's good this is this guy's kid
what does this guy do for a living is he
this is what he does or he's like I
don't know let's pull him I'm pulling up
his Twitter his name is Neil Agarwal I
think so he says creative coder
yeah this guy's cool
um yeah I like this personal portfolio
you had a pretty good portfolio website
that you had built uh do you like
maintain it or what did you do with it I
haven't updated it in a while but I will
say the page that gets the most traffic
or or really gets the most people who
contact me is my open page so a lot of
well not a lot some startups have an
open page uh that is we make this much
revenue we have this many page views and
normally they don't go much past that I
created an equivalent I haven't updated
it in a while but it was basically like
okay this is how much I make from my
personal projects but it's also my goals
and it's like if my goal for example is
I exercise 50 of the days in a year I
hooked it up to my spreadsheet and it
publicly tracks it daily so you can see
exactly how much I'm doing or it shows
what books I'm reading or I don't know
silly things like that but people seem
to love that for some reason yeah yeah
people do love that they wish they were
like as organized and on top and clear
about their goals as you that's why they
love it
but you only put your side project
revenue on here right
yeah I've actually you know what I have
debated I've been wanting to write an
article which is about
my like
could say monetary Ascent through life
um as in wow that's that's a that's like
post-economic my monetary no no that's
amazing I will say so the reason it's an
Ascent is not because I make so much now
but I just made so little starting out
and so I've been wanting to write about
that because it's kind of you know I
feel like I've learned some things but
also I think it'd be interesting to
actually publicly say in this year I
made X and and I've seen some
celebrities do this but you know 20
years later they're like look at my tax
returns right but I kind of want to do
it now and say look five years ago I was
making X and then I made X and and to
really like publicly share how much I
made how like what jobs they were Etc
and what I learned along the way but I
know I'm just gonna get trashed you know
what I mean because because saying you
make a bunch of money now is not it's
not something people love so I've stayed
away from it but I kind of want to
anyway yeah yeah I've thought about
those same things and I'm just like uh
why do I want to invite this in I don't
need this what's my a bunch of money
you're like I don't need to kind of
myself out there for the uh for
the attention anymore so there's kind of
this like this like counterproductive
thing where it's like well the reason I
would for me I'm very like simple which
is like uh people when they do that
stuff they're like I just want to
increase transparency in the world or
like you know I just want other people
like me to know you know I think you
know we should openly share I think we
should openly share strategies I think
we should openly share tactics I think
you should privately with a group of
trusted people share the your numbers
itself but to publicly for everybody
share how much you make I think only is
is in your interest when you're not
making that much but it's growing then
once you're making a bunch at that point
the kind of risk reward flips I think at
least
um and so you know I'm not that into
that but but this cool I noticed there's
no 2022 goals what happened we're almost
at the end I know I gotta I gotta post
it but I will say I'm way behind on them
so maybe that's why
are you are you like a goal hitter like
do you hit like most of these goals
no I mean I'm one of those people who I
hit some of them but that's how I think
it should be right if you're hitting 100
you're not setting ambitious goals if
you're hitting nothing then you're just
lost in the world probably but I hit
maybe 50 every year yeah I think at
Amazon they had said somebody had said
like 75 if you if you're hitting more
than 75 of your goals like you weren't
sufficiently
um ambitious if you're hitting less than
75 of your goals uh or like maybe maybe
it was a little bit less than that I
don't know but it was like you're not
executing well enough like you didn't
you didn't do a good enough job
um yeah okay uh all right what else we
got you got a bunch of ideas on here you
want to give us let's go some business
ideas
some quick ones okay so business ideas I
don't know if there's one like a new
business idea here but I thought this
was interesting I'm calling it salty
bowls and smelly water and so basically
there's two examples of everyone wants
to eat healthier uh that's I think a
pretty Universal human uh want at least
and two companies are doing something
interesting here so Kirin which is
k-i-r-i-n it's a company in Japan and
they partnered with the university and
they found a way to make to basically
use a super weak electrical current both
in bowls and Chopsticks so that when
you're eating something about the
ionization or the electric current makes
something taste saltier so you can
imagine like when you actually eat
something your taste buds or yeah what
there's some something happening
chemically on your tongue and they've
basically found a way to somewhat
reproduce this so you can actually eat
food every not everyone a lot of people
including myself love salty food you're
actually eating foods with less soda but
they taste salty and then I'm just going
to quickly tack on the other one which
is similar where it's I'm calling it
smelly water because it's this company
called air up which basically has found
a way to create a scented ring around a
bottle's lip so similarly they found a
way to make something taste better in
this case through scent instead of
electrical current and they I think
raised 68 million dollars and so I think
it's just this like interesting
phenomena of how do you make something
and there's the train how do you make
something taste good without actually
changing the caloric or the the intake
of the food and hang on your note here
says it's making 100 million plus a year
as like an estimate according to Glimpse
air up is this like flavored ring of the
bottle so you basically you bring a
bottle up to your lips the water itself
is not flavored the ring is scented or
flavored in some way so that when you
drink the water you get that you know
whatever hint of citrus or whatever
you're looking for is that it yes and I
put according to Glimpse because I
wasn't able to reproduce or like find
that number online I don't know where
they got it
um they definitely raised a bunch of
money I just don't know if that Revenue
number is correct
that is crazy wow
um have you tried either of these no I
want to I saw the Chopstick Bowl One
very recently so I kind of want to order
one and then I haven't tried air up
wow uh these are this is fascinating I
had not uh I didn't know you had said
the salty Bowl smelly water thing I
didn't understand what it was until you
said that but that's crazy I mean the
the sort of like salt taste without
without extra salt that's kind of I mean
that's that's kind of Genius if you
could do that all right you want to
close things off yeah we can wrap it up
where should people kind of find you
follow you where do they get your next
podcast that's coming out uh tell the
people what they want yeah so you can
find me at stephsmith.io or on Twitter
Steph smithio and then yeah we're gonna
be hopefully launching the podcast soon
the a16z podcast you can find it
anywhere that you find your podcast do
you have a name yet or or not yet it's
called the a16z podcast okay
yeah sorry
yeah
all right all right uh thanks for coming
on Steph and uh best of luck with the
Pod thanks
[Music]
foreign